Lebensmittel ein ganz anderes Thema es
wird gehen um die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung seit ja fast
rund 15 Jahren strahlte die deutsche
Politik über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung
vergangene Woche gab es dann erneut ein
Gerichtsurteil dazu der Europäische
Gerichtshof der hat nämlich der
Speicherung von
Telekommunikationsdaten zur Aufklärung
von Straftaten in Deutschland mit einem
neuen Urteil erneut sehr enge Grenzen
gesetzt der Europäische Gerichtshof hat
erklärt dass die seit 2017 ausgesetzte
deutsche Regelungen zur
Vorratsdatenspeicherung eben nicht mit
EU-Recht vereinbar sei eine allgemeine
und unterschiedslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung sei eben nur bei
einer sehr ernsten Bedrohung für den
nationale Sicherheit mit dem Europarecht
vereinbar aber der EuGH eröffnete
durchaus Spielräume für den nationalen
Gesetzgeber und genau über diese
Spielräume da streitet man sich unter
anderem auch durchaus innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition also wie kann man diese
wie möchte man diese Spielräume aus
wissen wenn es um die
vorratsanspeicherung eigentlich ist nur
noch um die Speicherung beispielsweise
von IP-Adressen geht darüber wird jetzt
debattiert werden unter anderem auf
Grundlage eines Antrags der
unionsfraktionen für die Union spricht
jetzt Andrea Lindholz
geehrte Frau Präsidentin
meine Seon Kindern vor Gewalt und
Missbrauch ist eine unserer wichtigsten
Aufgaben Kinder können sich nicht zur
Wehr setzen und leiden meist ein Leben
lang unter den Folgen sexuellen
Missbrauchs dieses Zitat der ehemaligen
Unabhängigen Beauftragten zur
Aufarbeitung von sexuelle Missbrauch
Frau Dr Christine Bergmann macht klar
worum es in der Debatte heute geht wir
debattieren heute darüber wie wir die
fast 14 Millionen Kinder und
Jugendlichen in Deutschland mit einem
ganz konkreten Vorschlag besser vor
sexuelle Missbrauch schützen können der
Europäische Gerichtshof hat in der
letzten Woche ein seit langem erwartetes
Urteil verkündet in diesem Urteil hat
der klargestellt dass zur Bekämpfung
schwerer Kriminalität eine befristete
anlasslose Speicherung von IP-Adressen
zulässig ist und genau das fordern wir
heute auch in unserem vorliegenden
Antrag der Europäische Gerichtshof hat
den mehreren Urteilen wie auch in diesem
aktuellen Urteil klargestellt und da
sind wir uns hier sicherlich alle einig
dass es sich bei sexuelle Missbrauch von
Kindern und Jugendlichen um ein
abscheuliches Verbrechen handelt und vor
allen Dingen um schwere Kriminalität und
auch die Herstellung und Verbreitung von
Fotos und Videos von diesen widerlichen
Taten gehört zweifellos zur schweren
Kriminalität dazu
warum ist aber gerade hier die
IP-Adressen Speicherung so dringend
notwendig das Internet es hat dazu
geführt dass Kinderschänder diese Fotos
und Videos viel einfacher verbreiten
können mit mehr als 39.000 Fällen im
Jahr 2021 haben sich die Fallzahlen
im Vergleich da zu davor quasi
verdoppelt es sind sage und schreibe
15.000 Fälle sexuellen
kindesmissbrauches im vergangenen Jahr
beim Bundeskriminalamt verzeichnet
worden und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das sind nur die bekannten
Fälle es zeigt sich also es gibt
dringenden Handlungsbedarf
die Aussage der Ermittler also der
Praktiker zu diesem Thema die sind
eindeutig erstens sagen Sie die
IP-Adresse des Computers oder des
Endgerätes mit dem eine entsprechende
Datei erworben verbreitet weitergegeben
oder bereitgestellt wird
ist meistens der einzige
Ermittlungsansatz für die Ermittler das
sieht im übrigen auch der Europäische
Gerichtshof in seinem Urteil so und ich
darf daraus zitieren
auszugsweise zur Bekämpfung von
sexuellen Missbrauch Kinderpornografie
und Ausbeutung von Kindern und so weiter
die IP-Adresse ist der einzige kann der
einzige Anhaltspunkt sein der es
ermöglicht die Identität der Person zu
ermitteln der diese Adresse zugewiesen
war als die Tat begangen wurde das sagt
und schreibt der Europäische Gerichtshof
zweitens immer wieder kann die
IP-Adresse einem konkreten Endgerät
nicht mehr zugeordnet werden weil die
Daten bereits gelöscht sind in den
vergangenen fünf Jahren konnten so
19.550 Hinweise auf sexuellen Missbrauch
in Deutschland nicht aufgeklärt werden
drittens wir brauchen daher eine mehrere
Monate dauernde Speicherpflicht wir
schlagen sechs Monate vor wir brauchen
das um Kinderschänder und ihre Netzwerke
abdecken und auch um laufenden sexuellen
Missbrauch zu verhindern
und schließlich viertens der sogenannte
quick freeze-vorschlag der FDP der
besagt dass man erst bei einem konkreten
Verdacht eine ip-adressenspeicherung
zulassen soll der ist und bleibt ein
Placebo auch die Ermittler teilen uns
ganz klar mit mit diesem Vorgehen würden
viele Ermittlungen ins Leere laufen denn
Daten liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
schon gelöscht wurden die können auch
nicht mehr eingefroren werden
es war mit der SPD in der vergangene
Legislaturperiode nicht möglich eine
Neuregelung zu fassen in der
Zwischenzeit hat aber Frau
bundesinnenministerin Feser
offensichtlich nach Rücksprache mit den
Praktikern die Notwendigkeit der
IP-Adressen Speicherung erkannt umso
beschämender für die Opfer und für
diejenigen die wir vor sexuelle
Missbrauch schützen wollen ist es aber
dass die FDP allen voran mit ihrem
fdp-justizminister sich nach wie vor
gegen die von uns geforderte IP-Adressen
Speicherung ausspricht gerade auch erst
wieder in dieser Woche obwohl Herr
Buschmann selbst hier in diesem Haus
noch in der letzten im Mai bei der
regierungsbefragung folgendes gesagt hat
er wolle den Ermittlungsbehörden
Instrumente angeben in der an die Hand
geben wie sie wirklich nutzen können das
wollen sie offensichtlich nicht
ausdrücklich mitgeteilt dass man die
Entscheidung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofes akzeptieren sollte ja dann
akzeptieren Sie die Entscheidung und
machen Sie Gebrauch von der Möglichkeit
der IP-Adressen Speicherung sie haben
gerade geklatscht ich will ihm zum
Abschluss nur eins sagen dieses
klatschen ist beschämend für alle Opfer
und für alle diejenigen die wir schützen
wollen und am Ende
Schutz vor Täterschutz gehen will gehen
soll
Herr Kollege Höferlin der Andrea
Lindholz war das hier zum Auftakt der
Debatte als Reaktion auf das Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs zur deutschen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung da fordert die
Union also in diesem Antrag eine
anlasslose sechs Monate gespeicherung
von IP-Adressen zur Verfolgung der
Straftaten des sexuellen
Kindesmissbrauchs oder auch
Kinderpornografie für die SPD jetzt
Sonja
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktionen bin sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren vor fast
genau einem Jahr wurde der 20 Deutsche
Bundestags gewählt gewählt erstmalig
gewählte Abgeordnete wie ich haben in
diesem Jahr sehr sehr viel gelernt auch
viele Routinen auch die Routine dass die
Union durch ihre Anträge immer wieder
versucht komplexe gesellschaftliche
Probleme mit einfachen Lösungen zu
beantworten aber diese einfachen Lösung
gibt es bei komplexen Problemen nicht
diese komplexe gesellschaftlichen
Probleme brauchen gerade differenzierte
Antworten gerade in einem Rechtsstaat
damit sie auch rechtssicher sind und das
hat doch zuletzt die Entscheidung des
eughs auch gezeigt wir reden hier in der
Tat über eines der sensibelsten
gesellschaftlichen Probleme wir reden
über den Schutz unserer Kinder wir reden
über den Schutz von Grundrechten und wir
reden über die Befugnisse unserer
Ermittlungsbehörden um eben diese
Grundrechte zu schützen die Grundrechte
der gesamten Bevölkerung ebenso wie die
Grundrechte unserer Kinder die es auch
gibt sehr geehrte Unionsfraktion
deshalb versuche ich jetzt mit etwas
Ruhe und Differenziertheit in die
Debatte einzusteigen
sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder müssen
wir bekämpfen wir brauchen dafür
natürlich auch technische Lösungen und
wir brauchen dafür aber auch eine
Stärkung der Prävention gegen diesen
sexuellen Missbrauch
der wichtigste Punkt
der wichtigste Punkt ist dabei die
Rechtssicherheit und die Effektivität
dieser Instrumente eine Rechtssicherheit
die es in den letzten Jahren eben nicht
gab und die auch durch die
höchstrichterliche Rechtsprechung immer
wieder betont wurde deshalb müssen wir
eine Antwort finden neben der nun
rechtswidrig festgestellten
Vorratsdatenspeicherung die anlasslos
war die eben kein effektives Mittel zur
Bekämpfung von sexuellen Missbrauch
gegen Kindern wahr zuletzt hat das
Urteil des eughs dieses festgestellt die
anlasslose Speicherung technischer Daten
durch Anbieter ist nichts rechts ist
nicht rechtssicher deshalb wollen wir
sehr schnell und sehr klar eine
anlassbezogene
Speicherung schaffen um die Aufklärung
von schweren Straftaten entsprechend zu
gewährleisten wir brauchen einen
Ausgleich zwischen den Betroffenen
Freiheitsrechten und den der Sicherheit
wir brauchen eine solide
Verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung und eine
effektive Bekämpfung von Straftaten bei
Kindesmissbrauch daran arbeitet sowohl
das Bundesinnenministerium als auch das
Justizministerium um die seit Jahren
andauernde Rechtssicherheit durch nun
effektive Konzepte endlich zu wieder
herzustellen
deshalb ist es sehr sehr gut dass die
Bundesregierung bereits jetzt an einem
Konzept für quick Fries arbeitet und
schnell einen Gesetzesvorschlag
vorliegen wird wir arbeiten daran das
Urteil entsprechend umzusetzen und wir
werden dabei auch zugleich alle
rechtlichen Möglichkeiten nutzen und
weitere prüfen um schwerste Straftaten
und Kriminalität eben entsprechend
rechtssicher zu bekämpfen zudem wollen
wir mit der login-falle ein ergänzendes
Instrument schaffen um Täterinnen und
Täter zu identifizieren
die sind erste wichtige Schritte bei der
Bekämpfung von schwerster Kriminalität
und hier stehen wir selbstverständlich
auch im Austausch mit unseren
Ermittlungsbehörden um eben in der
Praxis technisch umsetzbare und gute
Instrumente zu finden und zu schaffen
die es bisher so entsprechend nicht gab
aber auch die Ermittlungsbehörden und
Strafverfolgungsbehörden müssen wir eben
technisch und personell insbesondere
besser ausstatten um in den Bereich von
sexuellen Missbrauch von Hetze im Netz
von Cyber Straftaten und Terrorismus
besser die Kriminalität bekämpfen zu
können sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union dabei haben wir
gerade keine Scheuklappen auf wir suchen
aber nach rechtssicheren wegen was eben
gerade mit ihnen in der großen Koalition
nicht möglich war
aber um aber um in dieser Debatte auch
wirklich sachlich zu bleiben lohnt sich
auch einen Blick auf die Zahlen betonen
möchte ich dabei das natürlich jede
Straftat und jede nicht aufgeklärte
Straftat auch zu viel ist aber waren es
2016 noch 39,8 Prozent der
strafrechtlich relevanten Meldungen von
IP-Adressen die keinem Anschluss zu
ordnenbar war so waren es 2021 nur noch
3,4 Prozent
3,4 Prozent ich wiederhole von daher von
daher ist es doch gerade so dass die
Instrumente die wir haben die wir noch
aufbauen ausbauen werden und den Ansatz
den wir verfolgen dass er wirkt bei der
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
das entspricht gerade nicht dem Bild was
sie hier zeichnen wollen 96 Prozent sind
zwar immer noch vier Prozent zu viel
aber eine Zahl die sich zeigen lässt an
der wir weiter arbeiten werden mit den
entsprechenden Instrumenten und das
wissen sie auch durch eine
parlamentarische Anfrage die Sie Herr de
Vries an den Staatssekretär Satow vor
kurzem gestellt haben lassen Sie mich
aber auch noch darauf kommen dass bei
der Bekämpfung eben dieser Kriminalität
ist auch sehr wichtig ist präventiv
vorzugehen um eben gerade den sexuellen
von Missbrauch von Kindern zu bekämpfen
dafür brauchen wir eine bessere
gesellschaftliche Sensibilisierung eine
Stärkung der Beauftragten für
Kindermissbrauch bessere Schutzkonzepte
in Kitas und Schulen und insgesamt
müssen wir hervorheben dass Kinder
Träger von Rechten sind und Träger von
Grundrechten sind und Sie doch am besten
geschützt werden wenn eben diese
Kinderrechte auch im Grundgesetz
verankert werden sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Unionsfraktion sie sind herzlich
eingeladen eben unserem Vorhaben
Kinderrecht im Grundgesetz zu verankern
entsprechend auch zuzustimmen vielen
Dank
sonja eichwede war das für die
SPD-Fraktion ja unterschiedliche
Ansichten gibt es in der Ampelkoalition
tatsächlich über die Maßnahmen die man
jetzt ergreifen kann nach diesem Urteil
des Europäischen Gerichtshof auch zum
quick freeze-verfahren übrigens sagt die
Parteikollegin von Sonja eichwede
nämlich bundesinnenministerin das also
bei diesem quickfies Verfahren werden ja
Daten nur anlassbezogen eben und auf
richterliche Anordnung gespeichert da
sagt Nancy Phaser beispielsweise wenn
die Daten weg sind kann ich sie auch
nicht mehr einfrieren das ist also
durchaus skeptisch was dieses Instrument
anbelangt Fabian Jacobi für die AFD
jetzt am Rednerpult
einer sogenannten elektronischen
Fußfessel Anordnen der entlassene wird
mit einem Peilsender ausgestattet die er
nicht ablegen darf und über den sein
Aufenthaltsort ständig feststellbar ist
dass diese Maßnahme konsequent angewandt
weitere Straftaten erschweren oder
verhindern kann liegt nahe jemand der
genau weiß dass alle seine Bewegungen
überwacht werden der wird sich sehr
genau überlegen ob er Regeln Übertritt
tuter ist aber dennoch dann ist die
Aufklärung und Bestrafung seiner Taten
um vieles leichter als sie es sonst wäre
läge ist da nicht ebenso nahe diese
unzweifelhaft effektive Methode zur
Reduzierung von Straftaten einfach zu
verallgemeinern und jedem Bürger
beispielsweise mit der Einschulung einen
solchen Sender zu verpassen
wenn allgemein die Bewegung und der
jeweilige Aufenthaltsort aller Menschen
aufgezeichnet würden und entsprechend
nachvollzogen werden könnten wenn es
sich als nötigerweise sollte
natürlich würden die so gespeicherten
Daten streng geschützt der Zugriff
darauf nur ausgesuchten staatlichen
Stellen unter klar definierten
Voraussetzungen erlaubt abwegig na klar
aber effektiv wäre es schon nicht wahr
wie viele Straftaten könnten auf diese
Weise aufgeklärt oder von vornherein
verhindert werden
wollen sie sich mitschuldig an diesen
Taten machen indem sie sich dieser
kleinen Lästigkeit verweigern ihre
Freiheit würde dadurch gar nicht
eingeschränkt sie können ja weiterhin
gehen wohin Sie wollen es würde halt nur
aufgezeichnet wo sie hingehen tut
niemandem weh nur den Tätern unter uns
und sie sind ja kein Täter oder doch
genug der grotesken ist man versucht zu
sagen nur so Grotes ist eben diese
Vorstellung doch nicht es ist halt so
dass die Frage wo wir uns körperlich
aufhalten und bewegen mittlerweile
weniger über uns aussagt als die Frage
wo und wie wir uns in der Parallelwelt
des Internets bewegen und bezogen auf
das Internet haben die beiden ehemaligen
Volksparteien Vorstellungen entwickelt
die leider in die Richtung gehen dort
alle Menschen vorsorglich unter
staatliche Führungsaufsicht zu stellen
wie verurteilte Straftäter speziell die
christlich-sozial-demokratische Union
über deren Antrag wie hier beraten hat
zu dem Vorhaben einer allgemeinen und
anlasslosen Überwachung im Internet ein
fast schon fetischistisches Verhältnis
entwickelt sie versuchen unablässig
wieder und wieder entsprechende Ideen
zur Realität zu machen sie laufen dabei
immer wieder vor die Wand lernen aber
nichts daraus sondern stehen auf und
nehmen Anlauf für die nächsten Versuch
schon 2010 hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht den damaligen
Versuch gestoppt und zu tun hat vor
wenigen Tagen der EuGH befunden dass
auch die letzte Version ihres
überwachungsgesetzes rechtswidrig
gewesen ist und prompt kommt hier der
nächste Antrag der uns auffordert nun
müssten wir aber doch endlich wenigstens
die Lücken nutzen die der EuGH nach
ihrer Lesart dafür gelassen hat nein
müssen wir nicht dass der EuGH der
Meinung ist eine anlasslose Speicherung
von IP-Adressen sei unter bestimmten
Bedingungen mit den Vorschriften der
eu-vereinbar das bedeutet doch nicht
dass wir jetzt automatisch das Maximum
dessen aufreizen müssten was danach
vielleicht gerade noch geht nein wir
müssen viel mehr in eigener
Verantwortung entscheiden welcher
grundsätzlichen Vorstellung von unserer
Gesellschaft wir folgen wollen eine
freiheitliche Gesellschaft behandelt
nicht ihre Bürger vorsorglich wie
Straftäter und deshalb darf die
allgemeine und anlasslose Überwachung
keine Option sein und zwar weder im
realen Leben noch im Internet wenn das
Justizministerium wie angekündigt einen
konkreten Vorschlag für eine
anlassbezogene Datensicherung im
Internet vorliegt werden wir uns das
genau ansehen und dann werden wir die
möglicherweise auch zustimmen so wie die
cdu/cs so dass hier fordert allerdings
sicherlich nicht vielen Dank
ja die
IP-Adresse oder auch IP-Adresse das ist
ja sowas wie die digitale Anschrift im
Internet jeder Computer im Netzwerk oder
im Internet besitzt eine IP-Adresse die
dazu dient einen Computer im Netzwerk
eben eindeutig zu identifizieren das ist
quasi wie eine Art Telefonnummer mit der
man den Computer anwählen kann Liebe
cdu/csu-fraktionen uns eint das Ziel
Kinder vor sexualisierter Gewalt
effektiv schützen zu wollen dann hört es
aber leider auch schon auf und schade
dass Herr Merz bei dieser wichtigen
Debatte bei diesem wichtigen Thema
lieber in der letzten Reihe sitzt und
sich unterhält
dass sie in ihrem Antrag immer noch von
kinderpornografischen Material sprechen
zeigt sie haben sich ganz offensichtlich
trotz einer 15-Jährigen Debatte nicht
eingehen mit der Thematik beschäftigt
diese Begrifflichkeit wird aus guten
Gründen seit Jahren nicht mehr verwendet
in der Fachwelt spricht man schon lange
von Darstellung sexualisierter Gewalt
und auch sonst hinken sie derzeit
meilenweit hinterher denn anstatt die
Ideen voranzubringen die wir
gesamtgesellschaftlich Kinder online wie
offline vor sexualisierter Gewalt
schützen können verfolgen sie immer noch
die längst überholte
vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt in Form
der IP-Adressen die mit geltendem
Grundrecht schlicht und vereinbar sind
[Applaus]
und sie rennen immer gegen die gleiche
verfassungsrechtliche Wand und ich habe
dafür keinerlei Verständnis denn es ist
eine Scheindebatte die auf dem Rücken
der Betroffenen ausgetragen wird und in
dieser Form niemandem hilft
sie lenkt davon ab dass wir endlich
zielgerichtete Maßnahmen zur Abwehr von
konkreten Gefahren braucht
und
dabei geht es mit der CDU durchaus auch
anders das zeigen ihre Kolleginnen aus
Schleswig-Holstein dort wird auf
eineinhalb Seiten des Koalitionsvertrag
dezidiert beschrieben mit welchen
Maßnahmen Kinder vor sexualisierter
Gewalt geschützt werden können und das
schwarz-grüne Bündnis hat keine Sekunde
auf die unnütze
vordatenspeicherung und die Speicherung
der IP-Adressen verschwendet
stattdessen haben wir uns gemeinsam sehr
klar und gerade mit Blick auf die
Darstellung sexualisierter Gewalt an
Kindern führt tatsächlich effektive
Instrumente zur Strafverfolgung
ausgesprochen zum Beispiel durch das
sogenannte quickpreisverfahren für
dieses Verfahren spricht sich übrigens
auch der Deutsche Kinderschutzbund aus
und ich habe es in meiner letzten Rede
zu diesem Thema schon erklärt aber ich
wiederhole es gerne noch mal wir müssen
den Kampf gegen sexualisierte Gewalt an
Kindern umfassen betrachten und das tun
wir als Ampelkoalition
unser gemeinsames Ziel müsste es doch
sein dass möglichst keine Taten
passieren aber zu Prävention und
Aufarbeitung kein Wort in ihren Antrag
dabei geht es darum wie wir die
Kooperation von allen für den
Kinderschutz wichtigen Institutionen
voranbringen können die funktionierende
Schutzkonzepte in allen Bereichen in
denen sich Kinder und Jugendliche
bewegen etablieren wie wir alle Menschen
für das Thema und die Gewalt die Kinder
und Jugendlichen angetan wird
sensibilisieren und wie wir die Arbeit
der Unabhängigen Beauftragten für Fragen
der sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch und der
unabhängigen aufarbeitungskommission
Stärken arbeiten sie daran endlich mit
uns zusammen
und wenn ich auch noch eine Anmerkung
zum aktuellen Haushaltsentwurf loswerden
darf wenn Sie ganz konkret was tun
möchten leben sie mit ihren Haushältern
die unabhängige Beauftragte für Fragen
des sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch hat eine
wegweisende aufklärungs- und
Sensibilisierungskampagne erarbeitet
dafür sind die Mittel im kommenden
Haushalt noch nicht abgesichert und hier
können wir als Parlamentarier in Akzente
setzen die im Kampf gegen sexualisierte
Gewalt an Kindern wirklich wirksam sind
vielen Dank
Denise Lob war das für die Bündnis
Grünen die Obfrau im Familienausschuss
ja in der Ampelkoalition lehnen auch die
Grünen genauso wie die FDP übrigens die
anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung ab
und setzen auf das Quick
freeze-verfahren als Alternative
was mit der IP Datenspeicherung ist
darum dreht sich ja im Moment die
Debatte vor allem nach dem Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs Anke domscheid
Berg jetzt hier als nächste Rednerin für
die Linke liebe Kolleginnen
täglich grüßt das Murmeltier so
kommentierte dass der Logbuch
Netzpolitik Podcast das dräuflichste
Gerichtsurteil zur Rechtswidrigkeit
irgendeiner Vorratsdatenspeicherung es
war das fünfte Urteil dazu vom
Europäischen Gerichtshof die CDU hat
aber auch diesmal nichts draus gelernt
die Tinte auf dem Urteil waren auch gar
nicht trocken da kamen sie schon mit
einem neuen Vorschlag um die Ecke
nämlich einer anderslosen Speicherung
von IP-Adressen ja es stimmt der EuGH
kleine Spielräume lassen aber drei
Voraussetzungen gelten auch dann eine
Überwachungsmaßnahme muss nämlich
dreierlei sein erstens geeignet zweitens
angemessen und drittens verhältnismäßig
ich mache da gerne mal die erklärviren
für die CDU erstens ist sie geeignet
Zweck dieser Maßnahme soll sein Bilder
von sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder im
Internet zu verfolgen wie die CDU aber
kürzlich auf ihre eigene schriftliche
Frage von der Bundesregierung auf fuhr
gab es 2021 bei 96 Prozent dieser
Straftaten kein einziges Problem mit den
IP-Adressen nur in 3,4 Prozent der Fälle
war eine fehlende IP-Adresse überhaupt
ein ermittlungshindernis nehmen wir mal
an alle IP-Adressen wären gespeichert
wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass derartige
Straftäter zu Hause ihren privaten
Laptop benutzen und ihren eigenen
Telekom Internetanschluss Straftäter
haben keinen Bock auf Knast und sind
clever genug entweder einen öffentlichen
Internetanschluss benutzen oder aber
einen Tor Browser der verschleiert
nämlich ihre IP-Adresse die IP-Adressen
die sie da erfahren werden führen ins
Leere aber nicht zum Straftäter die
Maßnahme ist mithin nicht geeignet
wäre sie denn wäre sie denn angemessen
angemessen ist eine Überwachungsmaßnahme
dann wenn es keine Alternative gibt die
weniger Grundrechte verletzt wenn es um
96% aller Fälle schon ohne geht und es
mit Quick freeze zusätzlich in
Einzelfällen eine weniger
grundrechtsverletzende Variante gäbe ist
die Speicherung aller IP-Adressen eben
auch nicht angemessen viele
Verhältnismäßigkeit
für die Verhältnismäßigkeit vergleicht
man den Nutzen mit dem Ausmaß der
Grundrechtsverletzung wir haben also auf
der einen Seite ein Nutzen von ungefähr
0 auf der anderen Seite die
Grundrechtsverletzung permanent von 83
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland das
ist ganz klar auch für Dummies nicht
verhältnismäßig laut EuGH dürfen
Regierungen im übrigen einen Nutzen auch
nicht herbeifantasieren sie müssen ihn
belegen und ein Beleg für den Nutzen
einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt es
nicht auch nicht in der Version einer
anderslosen ip-adressespeicherung
außerdem hat die CDU offenbar die
Einschränkung des EuGH nicht verstanden
wonach die Speicherfrist auf das äußerst
Notwendige beschränkt sein muss bei
Ermittlungen schwerster Straftaten
sollten Behörden aber somit Personal und
Ressourcen ausgestattet sein dass sie
IP-Adressen auch in ein paar Tagen
abfragen können wie es voraussichtlich
dass quick Fries Verfahren bei konkreten
Verdachtsfällen ja auch vorsieht aber
nicht ein halbes Jahr meine Damen und
Herren es ist schon ehrlich gesagt eine
absolute Zumutung ein EuGH zum Teil so
auszureizen dass es eine maximale
massenüberwachung ermöglicht dabei aber
auch noch derartilettantische Fehler zu
machen ist einfach nur noch peinlich wer
greift denn freiwillig mehrfach immer
wieder in das gleiche Klo das ist die
CDU meine Damen und Herren
wenn es der CDU tatsächlich um den
Schutz von Kindern vor Gewalt ginge dann
hätte sie in 16 Jahren Regierungszeit
mehr dafür getan mit Prävention
derartige Gewalttaten zu verhindern
stattdessen mussten wir in der
Linksfraktion 16 Jahre lang gegen
ständige Ausbreitung anlassloser
Überwachung und für Prävention und den
Schutz von Kindern kämpfen ich bin froh
über die klare Absage an jede Form
anlassloser Überwachung im
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel und ich
hoffe sie bleibt auch dabei ich bin auch
froh dass die CDU der Bundesregierung
nicht mehr angehört 15 Jahre
rechtswidriger kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss fünf eugh-gerichtsurteile
sollten reichen das tote Pferd
Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehört nicht
weiter geritten sondern endgültig
begraben vielen Dank meine Damen und
Herren
danke deshalb war das für die
Linksfraktion jetzt kommt für die FDP
deren stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender Konstantin Kohle
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir sprechen heute über die Bekämpfung
von Straftaten nach der Entscheidung des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs in der
vergangenen Woche zur deutschen
anlasslosen Vorratsdatenspeicherung und
lassen Sie mich eine Bemerkung vorweg
machen wir reden über eine bestimmte
Form von Straftaten nämlich den
sexuellen Missbrauch an Kindern und
diese Form von Straftaten gehört zu dem
abscheulichsten und zu dem widerlichsten
was man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann
und wenn hier versucht wird denjenigen
die sich gegen die anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung einsetzen zu
unterstellen sie würden an der Seite von
Kinderschändern stehen oder sie würden
das sogar gut heißen was da passiert
dann bewegt sich das im Bereich von eher
abschneidenden Diffamierung das würde
ich ganz deutlich sagen
wir alle wir alle gemeinsam haben das
Interesse und haben das Ziel sexuellen
Missbrauch an Kindern zu verhindern und
zu bekämpfen das glaube ich Ihnen und
das sollten Sie uns auch glauben und den
Opfern ist überhaupt nicht geholfen wenn
wir uns da auseinander dividieren lassen
und ich bin ganz überzeugt davon auch in
vollem Respekt vor der praktischen
Expertise unserer Sicherheitsbehörden
dass wir eine gute Lösung dieser
Diskussion finden werden in der
vergangenen Woche hat der Europäische
Gerichtshof eine ganz wichtige
Entscheidung veröffentlicht und damit
einen Meilenstein für die Bürgerrechte
markiert eine anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist mit
europäischen Grundrechten unvereinbar
das zeigt noch einmal eine
massenüberwachung bei der alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit Blick auf
ihre Verkehrsdaten mit Blick auf ihre
Standortdaten überwacht werden passt
nicht zu unserer Werteordnung und weil
das so ist müssen die Bundesregierung
und der Bundestag jetzt das einzig
richtige machen was aus diesem Urteil
folgen kann und das ist die anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung aus deutschen
Gesetzen zu streichen meine Damen und
Herren
und es hat ja in der Woche in der wir
jetzt sind ein Treffen gegeben der
Innen- und Justizminister in München und
da habe ich teilweise gedacht ich bin im
falschen Film seit 15 Jahren sprechen
wir in Deutschland darüber dass die
anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung
rechtswidrig ist seit 15 Jahren wissen
wir bestätigt durch mehrere
Gerichtsurteile dass dieses Instrument
von den Behörden eben nicht eingesetzt
werden kann und wir wissen dank der
Zahlen die hier gerade von der Kollegin
eichwede vorgetragen worden sind dass
die Aufklärungsquote gerade beim
sexuellen Missbrauch bei Kindern
trotzdem relativ hoch ist und jetzt
kommt Marco Buschmann und macht Ihnen
ein Angebot wie man diese
Aufklärungsquote auch noch steigern
können und statt sich darauf einzulassen
lehnen sie das ab da habe ich wirklich
überhaupt nicht mehr verstanden was mit
den innenministerland in diesem Land
eigentlich los ist meine Damen und
Herren ich will ihnen das ganz klar
sagen wer sich einer Diskussion über den
Quick Fries Ansatz verweigert der ist
doch in Wahrheit das Sicherheitsrisiko
was er vorwirft zu sein und deswegen
sollten wir schnellstmöglich in eine
Diskussion darüber einsteigen diesen
quick Fries Ansatz auf den Weg zu
bringen und dann höre ich immer
IP-Adressen das sei ja nicht so schlimm
natürlich ist eine IP-Adresse ein
sensibles Datum denn eine it-adresse
ermöglicht in der Zusammenschau mit
anderen gespeicherten Daten eine sehr
genaue Auskunft darüber wie das
Surfverhalten einer Person im Internet
ist und dieses permanente Gefühl des
überwachtseins passt nicht zu einer
liberalen Demokratie diese Situation
passt nicht zu einer freiheitlichen
Gesellschaft und natürlich leben wir in
Deutschland in einem freien Land
natürlich haben wir einen
funktionierenden Rechtsstaat aber wir
müssen doch auch mal sehen welchen
systemkonflikt wir gerade auf der Welt
haben da geht es darum das Autokratien
und Demokratien gegeneinander stehen und
Demokratien werden diesen systemkonflikt
nur bewältigen wenn Sie auch bei der
Verbrechensbekämpfung dazu stehen was
ihre eigenen Grundwerte sind und das
gilt auch bei der Verteidigung der
informationellen Selbstbestimmung und
auch bei der Verteidigung der
Privatsphäre
und diese Debatte sagt doch so viel aus
sie sagt doch so viel darüber aus wie
das Verständnis unterschiedlicher
Fraktionen hier im Haus ist wenn es um
das Verhältnis von Staat und Bürgern
geht es gibt Menschen die wissen dass
bei zusätzlichen
freiheitseinschränkungen und ja es
braucht freiheitseinschränkungen um
Straftaten zu bekämpfen und zu ahnten
dass der Souverän von
freiheitseinschränkungen überzeugt
werden muss und es gibt andere in diesem
Haus die glauben dass man den souverän
mit freiheitseinschränkungen und
überrumpeln kann indem man eine Debatte
ansetzt über sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch
aber eigentlich will man die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung einfach generell
im deutschen Recht wieder haben dann wir
sie auch für andere Straftaten man will
sie auch für Straftaten die sie ein wo
sie sich schon für eingeführt haben und
deswegen ist das auch eine Masche die
sie hier aufführen und dieser Masche
werden wir nicht folgen wir werden als
Ampelkoalition eine gute Lösung finden
einen guten Kompromiss zwischen
Sicherheit und Freiheit wir werden die
Aufklärungsquote war der Bekämpfung von
sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch weiter
steigern das sind wir den Opfern
schuldig und wir sind das auch unserer
Werteordnung schuldig dass wir das in
vollem Respekt vor der Freiheit vor der
informationellen Selbstbestimmung und
auch vor dem Schutz der Privatsphäre tun
herzlichen Dank
coole war das für die Liberalen ja an
dieser Einigung innerhalb der
Ampelkoalition da wird derzeit
gearbeitet wenn man den
Fachpolitikern und den Stimmen aus der
Fraktion
zuhört tatsächlich
wander sozusagen die Einigung stehen
wird das ja steht noch auf einem anderen
Blatt deswegen hören wir jetzt erstmal
noch Günther Krings zu für die
Unionsfraktion der hier diesen Antrag
gestellt hat der Grundlage dieser
Debatte ist
heutigen Tag werden Stunde für Stunde
kinderpornografische Bilder und
ekelerregende Videos hochgeladen und zu
viele Missbrauchstäter können wir nicht
zur Strecke bringen und ich will daher
mein Minuten nutzen die ampelbeiträge in
dieser Debatte gern noch mal mit vier
Hinweisen vom Kopf auf die Füße zu
stellen erstens der einzige
Ermittlungsansatz gegen Kindesmissbrauch
ist in den meisten Fällen die IP-Adresse
der täter-computer diese wirkt wie ein
Autokennzeichen im Netz nur dass sie
eben jeden Tag dieses Kennzeichen
gewechselt wird deshalb werden wir den
Missbrauch nur dann wirksam und
vollständig bekämpfen können wenn wir es
schaffen dass diese Adressen gespeichert
werden
zweitens lesen Sie Gerichtsurteile bitte
ganz sie jubeln mit Blick auf das
EuGH-Urteil über die Unzulässigkeit
eines wirksamen digitalen
verhandlungsinstrument zum Schutz
unserer Kinder sie mögen das feiern wir
tun das nicht
für uns ist die gute Nachricht die
Entscheidung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs aus der letzten Woche lässt
genau die beschriebene Möglichkeit zur
Speicherung von IP-Adressen zu um damit
schwere Straftaten bekämpfen zu können
meine Damen und Herren
und ich hoffe doch ich hoffe doch dass
wir uns in diesem Hause zumindest noch
darauf einigen können dass sie sich bei
Kinderpornografie und Kindesmissbrauch
genau um solche schwerste Kriminalität
handelt da können sie eigentlich
klatschen wir tun es nicht
daher wollen wir genau diese Möglichkeit
des Urteils auch konsequent nutzen und
es ist aufschlussreich dass weite Teile
dieses Hauses gerade diesen zentralen
Teil des Urteils einfach ausblenden wer
ein Gerichtsurteil so selektiv liest wie
sie das tun der missbraucht einen
Richterspruch für seine politische
Agenda das ist nicht in Ordnung
drittens seien Sie nicht länger Teil des
Problems sondern werden Sie Teil der
Lösung seit weit über einem Jahrzehnt
höre ich in diesem Hause von den Grünen
von der FDP von weiten Teilen der SPD
immer die gleiche kampfrätorik gegen die
verkehrsdatenspeicherung wir nehmen die
Entscheidung des Verfassungsgerichts des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs ernst und
arbeiten auf ihrer Grundlage an neuen
Strategien zur Kriminalitätsbekämpfung
ihnen fällt seit Jahren nichts anderes
ein als die Vorratsdatenspeicherung muss
weg wie das dieser ausgedrückt wird das
ist muss weg Politik ohne eine Antwort
was stattdessen kommen soll Kollege
Krings möchten Sie eine Zwischenfrage
des Kollegen Dr von Nots zulassen
geschätzter Kollege kriegens vielen Dank
für das Zulassen der Zwischenfrage Herr
Krings 16 lange Jahre 16 lange Jahre hat
die Union das BMI inne gehabt und sie
waren ja mit in Verantwortung
wer soll ihnen eigentlich noch abnehmen
nach all den betreuerungen dass ihre
Gesetzesvorschläge im Bereich der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung aber diesmal
wirklich verfassungskonform sind ja aber
diesmal wirklich ja wenn das hier ihr
Vortrag ist nachdem sie zum fünften Mal
vor höchsten Gerichten gescheitert sind
und jetzt einfach redundant denselben
Kram erzählen den sie die letzten
Jahrzehnte hier erzählt haben und ich
sage Ihnen mal eine Sache sie ist sie
legen hier sozusagen mit dem Impetus es
geht ja tatsächlich um ein sehr ernstes
Thema aber erklären Sie mir mal die
Diskrepanz zwischen dem Ärzten Thema
dass wir hier verhandeln und ihrem
dünnsten zweiseitigen lieblosensten copy
and pace-antrag den Sie hier vorliegen
indem sie überhaupt nicht auf das
Gerichtsurteil eingehen sie beantworten
all die relevanten Fragen nicht es sind
ja es ist ja mega voraussetzungsvoll wie
IP-Adressen gespeichert werden deswegen
legen sie mal da genau anhand des
Urteils wie sie das umsetzen wollen dann
kann man vielleicht in der ernsthafte
Diskussion kommen sonst hat man den
Eindruck dass sie einfach redundant das
fordern was sie immer fordern und mit
dem sie mega unerfolgreich waren
herzlichen Dank
es ist ja eine beliebtes rhetorisches
Mittel wenn man der Sache keine
Argumente hat hat Personen zu
argumentieren
das kann man machen das kann man machen
auch ich bin nicht glücklich mit allem
was wir im Innenministerium in den
letzten Jahren machen konnten weil wir
hatten die ganze Zeit Koalitionspartner
die manche Dinge nicht ermöglicht haben
sie greifen mit ihrer Einlassung
zugleich zwölf Jahre SPD und vier Jahre
FDP mitregierung an das könnte in Ampel
diskutieren aber ich habe mehr Spaß
daran in der Sache zu diskutieren sie
hoffentlich eigentlich auch und die Zahl
von Gerichtsurteilen zu zählen ich meine
gibt es einen schönen Satz judex nur ein
kalkulat ist noch nie ein starkes
juristisches oder politisches Argument
gewesen sondern entscheidend ist das
muss ein Urteil die richtigen
Konsequenzen zieht setzt allerdings
voraus man liest es und zwar vollständig
und ich könnte jetzt eine Reihe von
ranziffern des Urteils zitieren aber
vielleicht reicht es fettgedruckte Teil
ist ja etwas einfacher vielleicht
aufzunehmen auch wenn vielleicht Teil
der Ampel schon überfordert sind mit
einem zwei seitigen Antrag von uns der
dritte spiegelstrich bei den
schlussfeststellungen sagt eindeutig
dazu Bekämpfung schwerer Kriminalität
natürlich eine IP-Adressen Speicherung
möglich ist bewegen uns hundertprozentig
auf der Grundlage des Urteils auch wir
haben in der Fraktion auch mit Richtern
gesprochen mit Europa Rechtsexperten die
Sache ist das klar diese Möglichkeit
besteht sie wollen sie nicht nutzen dann
sagen Sie das offen sie wollen sie nicht
nutzen das kann man politisch wollen die
rechtliche Möglichkeit ist da wir wollen
sie nutzen es ist hier in der Frage
nicht das rechtlichen können sondern des
politischen Wollens und diese
Entscheidung muss hier in diesem
Parlament getroffen werden meine Damen
und
und wenn ich fortfahren darf Frau
Präsidentin kommen Sie mir bitte auch
nicht immer wieder mit dem
Ablenkungsmanöver quick Fries denn
dadurch würde eben nichts verbessert es
nützt halt nichts wenn Sie die
IP-Adresse von letzter Woche brauchen
für die altataufklärung aber erst heute
den Gefrierschrank befüllen Sie halten
mit diesem Thema der Öffentlichkeit hier
seit Jahren einen bloßen Pappkameraden
hin einfrieren meine Damen und Herren
können Sie damit allenfalls ihr eigenes
schlechtes Gewissen und vier
viertens reden Sie bitte mit Praktikern
das ist gar nicht so schwer ist auf
einem auf einem konstruktiven Kurs
umzuschwenken zeigt Ihnen doch ihre
eigene bundesinnenministerin und das
zeigen übrigens auch wie eben gesagt
worden ist dankenswerter Weise ihre
eigenen Landesinnenminister die Hälfte
aller Landesinnenminister sind SPD
Innenminister und auch die sind der
Auffassung die Datenspeicherung ist
nicht nur möglich sondern auch richtig
und das gleiche sagten dann
bemerkenswert Interview ihr
Fraktionskollege aus dem Rechtsausschuss
der SPD Herr Fiedler eigentlich komisch
also heute in Debatte nicht sprechen
darf ist zumindest da schön dass Sie da
sind tolles Interview und sie sind
unsere Auffassung dafür ganz herzlichen
Dank
die Innenministerin
fordert inzwischen die IP-Adressen
Speicherung weil sie nämlich einfach mal
mit Praktikern im Bundeskriminalamt
gesprochen hat und deshalb wäre es schön
wenn etwa auch der Bundesjustizminister
einmal sozusagen aus dem Elfenbeinturm
seines Ministerbüros herabsteigt und mit
Praktikern spricht
und ich finde die Strafverfolger werden
dann schon ihm erzählen über welche
grausamen Realitäten es sich hier
handelt wobei das glaube ich ist gar
nicht hier nur der entscheidende Punkt
der zweite Punkt auch was Sie brauchen
was sie als Instrumente brauchen um
diese Taten wirksam bekämpfen zu können
ich glaube das muss man einfach
akzeptieren dass auf dich wirken lassen
und entsprechend glaube ich würde man
die Meinung ändern meine Damen und
Herren hier im Deutschen Bundestag muss
die Ampel jetzt Farbe bekennen wollen
sie die immer noch Hunderte und Tausende
von Fällen auch wenn es weniger geworden
sind unaufgeklärten fortgesetzten
Kindesmissbrauchs einfach mit einem Axel
zucken hinnehmen oder sind Sie bereit
gemeinsam mit uns die
computer-ip-adressen als wirksame Waffe
zum Schutz und zur Rettung gepeinigte
Kinder einzusetzen ganz einfache Frage
mein Appell entscheiden sich gegen
Ignoranz und für Kinderschutz vielen
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
für die spd-fraktionsprüche ist Herr
Kollege Dr Jens Zimmermann
es ist der digitalpolitische Sprecher
der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute Klammer auf mal wieder Klammer zu
über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und man
könnte sagen das ist ein guter Anlass
wir haben das in verschiedenen
Ausschüssen diese Woche auch getan weil
wir das Urteil des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs haben aber der Anlass ist
ja nicht dass wir hier mal eine muntere
selbstbefassung machen das wird jetzt
vielleicht gerade aus dieser Debatte
sondern dass die Union ganz schnell und
fix hier einen Antrag gestrickt hat aber
es ist eben schon deutlich geworden der
Kollege von Notz hat darauf hingewiesen
der ist ja jetzt nicht sehr dick geraten
der hat zwei Seiten und ist auch nicht
sonderlich ausgegoren ich bin mir nicht
hundertprozentig sicher liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen der Union ob dieser
Antrag diese Ernsthaftigkeit die Sie bei
der Debatte einfordern ob der den auch
nur ansatzweise widerspiegelt Liebe
und wir sprechen heute deswegen auch
über Sicherheit und über den Schutz von
Kindern und über Maßnahmen die der Staat
ergreifen kann und diese zu schützen und
ich glaube alle Rednerinnen und Redner
aus allen Fraktionen haben deutlich
gemacht dass das ein gemeinsames
Anliegen ist aber das will ich auch
sagen man muss natürlich auch mal
schönes neudeutsches Wort den Track
Record der Union anschauen und der ist
in diesem Bereich ja wirklich verheerend
meine Damen und Herren das was sie in
den letzten 16 Jahren in dem Bereich
erreicht haben und sie sagen ja so schön
hätten sie nicht mit der FDP regieren
müssen hätten sie nicht mit der SPD
regieren müssen dann hätten sie noch
viel mehr hinbekommen aber das Wenige
was sie da machen wollten überall wo
viele sich die Hände schon über den Kopf
zusammengeschlagen haben das ist doch
alles vor Gerichten gescheitert also das
ist doch irgendwie ziemlich unlogisch
was Sie hier
präsentieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und immer wenn wir diese
Abwägung haben von Sicherheit und von
Freiheit vom Eingriff in
bürgerinnenrechte um den Schutz
anderer das ist doch ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt da brauchen sie doch nicht so zu
brüllen der Punkt ist aber doch das
setzt immer auch Vertrauen der Bürger
innen in diesen Staat voraus und wenn
ich mir dann mal Stichwort ihre Bilanz
anschaue wenn sie dann Leute wie ein
Hans-Georg Maaßen in wichtige Funktionen
setzen die es an der ganzssensiblen
Stelle von Sicherheit und Bürgerrechten
sind dann müssen sie sich doch nicht
wundern dass niemand mehr Vertrauen hat
in Sie bei diesem Thema liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
es ist es ist ein Fakt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aber mir ist vor allem eins
wichtig wenn wir das Thema sich die
Fakten anschaut dann muss doch an
vorderster Stelle und das ist ja auch
Ihre Anfrage gewesen an das
Bundesinnenministerium das für
Transparenz gesorgt hat man muss doch
mal an vorderster Stelle einen großen
Dank an alle Ermittlerinnen und
Ermittler setzen denn das
Bundeskriminalamt und die Ermittlerinnen
und Ermittler haben in den letzten
Jahren ja für ja die Festsetzung die
Feststellung von IP-Adressen von
Nutzerinnen und Nutzern von IP-Adressen
nach oben getrieben auf
96,5% im letzten Jahr deswegen sage ich
ganz klar ein herzlichen Dank an diese
harte Arbeit die dort geleistet wurde
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist die Situation die wir aktuell
haben und da können Sie noch so viel
brüllen das sind ja die Zahlen die sie
angefordert haben die müssten man
natürlich auch mal verstehen das würde
bei der ganzen Geschichte helfen und das
europäische der Europäische Gerichtshof
man wir haben dann ja alle immer mal mit
höchstrichterlicher Rechtssprechung aber
am Ende des Tages müssen wir das auch
zur Kenntnis nehmen und es hilft auch
nichts dann da Krokodilstränen zu
vergießen sondern wir haben jetzt vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht vom
Europäischen Gerichtshof ein ganz klaren
Rahmen in dem wir arbeiten müssen und
erster Punkt ist die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung wie sie sie
immer haben wollten ist weder mit
deutschem noch mit europäischen Recht
vereinbar und die Dinge die das
europäisch die der Europäische
Gerichtshof am Ende in seinem Urteil als
Alternativen aufmacht die hat die
Bundesregierung und die haben die
koalitionsfraktion bereits im
koalitionsver aufgeführt natürlich das
Thema das Thema quick freeze Herr
Kollege das Thema quick freeze hat ja
sogar das EuGH der schreibt der hat zwar
nicht quick freeze genannt aber ist doch
ganz klar das ist da drin das werden wir
umsetzen das ist ein wirksames
Instrument liebe Kollegin und Kollegen
und insofern ich lese ich lese Ihnen
auch gerne noch mal vor was wir
vereinbart haben wir werden die
Regelungen zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung
so ausgestalten dass Daten rechtssicher
an das bezogen nicht anlasslos und durch
richterlichen Beschluss gespeichert
werden können also ich glaube diese
diese diese aufgeregte Diskussion von
ihnen da sage ich mal da hätte ich mir
mal einen Quick freeze für Ihren Antrag
gewünscht das hätte vielleicht geholfen
ein quick freeze für den Antrag weil
weil nein das arrogant Herr Kollege
arrogant ist es arrogant ist es zwei
drei Tage nach dem Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofes mir nichts
dir nichts einen kleinen quick and dirty
Antrag hier reinzubringen um genau diese
Debatte die jetzt hier läuft zu
provozieren sie haben kein Interesse an
einer pragmatischen Lösung und deswegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen bin ich
sehr dankbar dafür dass Minister
Buschmann und Ministerin Faser einen
Vorschlag vorlegen werden der
europa-rechtskonform ist und deswegen
den Kampf gegen Kindesmissbrauch endlich
voranbringen wird und uns nicht weitere
16 Jahre behindern wird wie ihre Arbeit
herzlichen Dank
ins Zimmermann war das für die
Sozialdemokraten deren
digitalpolitischer Sprecher aus der
Fraktion ja er hat auch noch mal den
Unterschied deutlich gemacht auf der
einen Seite des quick freeze-verfahren
bei dem Daten Anlass bezogen gespeichert
werden auf der anderen Seite die
Speicherung von IP-Adressen die dann
anlasslos und 6 monatig beispielsweise
sein soll nach dem Willen der
Unionsfraktion
gereon Bollmann jetzt hier als nächster
Redner für die AFD in dieser Debatte
meine Damen und Herren ich denke der
bisherige Verlauf der Debatte erweist
dass wir uns alle zumindest in einem
Punkt sehr einig sind oder einig sein
dürften das nämlich die sexualisierte
Gewalt an Kindern als der
abscheulichsten Verbrechen ist das ist
eigentlich ziemlich klar und auch dass
deren Bekämpfung ein äußerst wichtigstes
Ziel wichtiges Ziel von Politik ist
steht wohl auch nicht zur infrage der
Datenschutz ist es aber auch und weil er
es ist haben eben in der letzten Woche
wieder einmal zwei Regierungen vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof Schiffbruch
erlitten die französische und die
deutsche beide Regierung hatten die
Freiheitsrechte der Bürger einmal mehr
nicht hinreichend in den Blick genommen
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt eine
sorgfältige Abwägung von Rechtsgütern
und kein Schnellschuss der Anhänger
einer eines Überwachungsstaates
schon jetzt lassen sich drei von vier
Fällen von sexualisierte Gewalt an
Kindern aufklären die amerikanische
Kinderschutzorganisation
ncmic überwacht nahezu sämtliche
Netzaktivitäten in dieser Richtung von
dieser Organisation erhält das BKA die
erforderlichen Daten und zwar ganz ohne
Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland
niemand kann doch seriös vorrechnen wie
hoch die Aufklärungsquote wäre wenn
sämtliche IP-Adressen gespeichert werden
kein Anlass also zu übertriebener Hektik
vielleicht an dieser Stelle immer voll
Lindholz sie haben ja die Debatte mit
ihrem Vortrag eröffnet sie sind
Fachanwältin für Familienrecht ich war
Richter in einem Familien Senat im
Oberlandesgericht wir sollten beide also
wissen von mir reden sie haben natürlich
die Passage zutreffend zitiert aber die
Bedingungen die zugleich in dem Urteil
stehen in dem von dem EuGH die haben sie
nicht angesprochen wir haben sie hier
von den von der Kollegin von den Linken
referiert bekommen auch Herr Jacobi hat
im Grunde darauf Bezug genommen das ist
zulässig habe eben nur bedingt was
nämlich was was nämlich Frau Lindholz
steht auf dem Spiel was steht auf dem
Spiel mit Ihrer Erlaubnis frau
Präsidentin ich zitiere eine andere
Stelle mal also gut zuhören danach ist
nämlich möglich die verkehrs- und
Standortdaten die zehn Wochen bzw vier
Wochen lang gespeichert werden sehr
genaue Schlüsse auf das Privatleben der
Person deren Daten gespeichert wurden
etwa auf Gewohnheiten des täglichen
Lebens beständige oder vorübergehende
Aufenthaltsorte das ist doch die Folge
dr Krings tägliche oder in anderen
Rhythmus erfolgende Ortsveränderungen
ausgeübte Tätigkeiten soziale
Beziehungen dieser Person und und jetzt
kommt das soziale Umfeld das soziale
Umfeld in dem sie verkehren und
insbesondere die Erstellung eines
Profils ermöglichen Zitat Ende
liebe Kollegen man kann nicht häufig
genug betonen dass dies fast
ausschließlich Personen betreffen würde
die doch mit Kriminalität überhaupt
nichts am Hut haben weiter heißt es in
dem Urteil dass die Bekämpfung schwerer
Kriminalität zwar von größter Bedeutung
sei aber für sich genommen die
Erforderlichkeit einer Maßnahme der
allgemeine unterschiedslosen
Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht
rechtfertigen könnte ich komme zum
Schluss frau Präsidentin aus genau
diesen Gründen lehnen wir eine
anlasslose Datenspeicherung ab nur bei
hinreichendem Tatverdacht und ich
betonen nur mit richterlichen Beschluss
sind Eingriffe in informationelle
Selbstbestimmung akzeptabel nicht aber
durch ein gesetzlichen Freifahrtschein
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
unser Kollege hege Limburg hat das Wort
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Union
wiederholt heute ein altbekanntes Ritual
unter der Überschrift Kinderschutz
Folgen rechtshistorische Ausführungen
zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung keine
einzige konkrete Forderung zum
Kinderschutz in diesem Land und dann als
einzige als einzige Forderung die
Einführung der anlasslosen
massenspeicherung im Internet das ist
erbärmlich wenig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und es ist auch falsch die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist
verfassungswidrig sie hat tief in die
Grundrechte aller Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in diesem Land eingegriffen sie gehört
in der Tat ins rechtshistorische Seminar
aber nicht ins Bundesgesetzblatt
im Bereich des Kinderschutzes meine
Kollegin lobesdorf schon eingegangen hat
sich diese Koalition viel vorgenommen
das ist in der Tat in diesem Land auch
viel zu tun für uns alle niemand von uns
kann doch in Wahrheit für sich in
Anspruch nehmen genug getan zu haben
wir könnten diskutieren über die
flächendecknachrichtung von
schalltod-häusern wo Kindern Geschütze
Umgebung Aussagen können über Konzepte
zur Stärkung von Kindern Nein zu sagen
oder auch wie wir Strukturen in
Verbänden und Institutionen erkennen
können die Kindesmissbrauch begünstigen
aber wenn Sie liebe Union ausgerechnet
in der Woche in der eine Studie zum
Thema Missbrauch im Breitensport
veröffentlicht worden ist das Thema
Kinderschutz hier auf die Tagesordnung
zu setzen ohne auch nur eine einzige
Forderung oder einen einzigen Gedanken
aus dieser Studie irgendwie aufzugreifen
weder in ihren Reden noch in ihrem
Beitrag sondern stattdessen eins und
allein sich fokussieren auf die
anlasslose massendatenspeicherung im
Internet dann darf uns das zumindest
häufig ausgedrückt verwundern
liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie ist denn
eigentlich der derzeitige Stand bei der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung nach 16 Jahren
unionsinnenminister mein Kollege von
Notz hat das gesagt es gibt sie schlicht
nicht 16 Jahre haben in diesem Bereich
exakt nichts hinterlassen quasi eine
schwarze Null
sie haben tief in die Grundrechte der
Menschen in diesem Land eingegriffen sie
haben dafür zu Recht Urteil aus
Karlsruhe aus Luxemburg kassiert die
Ihnen diese Eingriffe attestiert haben
aber sie haben eben nichts vorgelegt was
tatsächlich die Rechte von Kindern
schützen würde oder den Ermittlerinnen
und
ermittlerninstrumente an die Hand geben
würde liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Krings sie haben uns unterstellt
wir würden hier sagen die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung muss weg nein
das ist nicht wahr die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist weg sie war
auch wenn es hier nicht passt in den
letzten Jahren nie da und insofern muss
es doch hier darum gehen wie ist der
Kollege Kuhn und andere trägt getan
haben mal zu diskutieren wie wir nach
vorne kommen können wie wir
ermittlungsinstrumente an die Hand geben
können
quick freeze liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das schnelle Einfrieren von
Daten im Internet ist natürlich auch ein
Eingriff im Grundrechte keine Frage aber
erst anlassbezogen und im Einzelfall und
nicht anlasslos und massenhaft und
deswegen ist es ausgewogen und
verhältnismäßig
Frau Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir diskutieren doch gerade auf
verschiedenen Ebenen wie wir die
Resilienz gegen Cyberangriffe stärken
können Cyberangriffe zum Beispiel aus
Russland können natürlich nicht nur den
Deutschen Bundestag treffen sondern auch
sämtliche Telekommunikationsunternehmen
in Deutschland sie von der Union wollen
das sämtliche
Telekommunikationsunternehmen eine
riesige datenvorratskammer anlegen wo
die Kommunikation jede und jedes
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
lückenlos für sechs Monate
rückverfolgbar ist das ist ihr Ziel was
machen Sie eigentlich wenn diese Daten
in falsche Hände gelangen in die Hände
ausländischer Geheimdienste liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der beste
Datenschutz ist Datensparsamkeit weil es
eben auch vor Missbrauch von Datenschutz
und auch deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
das hier so nicht machen wie sie das
Vorschlagen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es ist in der Tat schon über
Ausnahmen der Europäische Gerichtshof
lässt diskutiert worden und Herr Krings
der Vorwurf das Urteil selektiv zu lesen
fällt auf die Union zurück als Ausnahme
ist in der Tat erwähnt dass für ein
absolut notwendig begrenzten Zeitraum
Speicherung denkbar wäre absolut
notwendig begrenzter Zeitraum sie
fordern allen Ernstes für sechs Monate
lang die Daten zu speichern Herr Krings
wenn Sie ernsthaft glauben dass das dass
das mit absolut begrenzter Zeitung
gemeint gewesen ist dann bewegen sie
sich am Rande der Lächerlichkeit ein
solches Gesetz würde zu Recht wieder von
höchstem diskutiert werden
ich komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
gut es gibt keine Strafverfolgung jeden
Preis es gibt darf kein anlasslosen
Generalverdacht geben wir werden für ein
ausgewogenes Verhältnis von den
legitimenstrafe Forschungsinteressen und
den Grundrechten der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sorgen die fortschrittskoalition
macht sich auf den Weg und ich wäre froh
wenn die Union sich endlich
konstruktiver beteiligen würde vielen
Dank
gegen den Burg war das der
rechtspolitische Sprecher der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Alexander
Rednerpult da ist er schon Alexander
droben für die Union
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin und
Kollegen ist schon bemerkenswert nicht
eher
erschreckend wie oberflächlich und
teilweise auch kaltschnäuzig manche
Redner manche Redner der Ampel
insbesondere von FDP und Grüne hier auch
über das Leid von Kinder bei
Kindesmissbrauch einfach hinweg geredet
wird und ihr ideologisches Steckenpferd
geritten wird es wirklich erschreckend
diese Woche eine kleine Anfrage der FDP
vom Dezember 20 in die Hände gefallen
unter anderem coole tome Buschmann
Höferlin die diese gestellt haben immer
versuchen immer versuchen sie mit ihren
eigenen Worten zu überzeugen dass wir
bei den IP-Adressen Weiterkommen müssen
bei der anlasslosen Speicherung sie
sagen sexualisierte Gewalt die sich
gegen Kinderrechte das eine der
schwersten Straftaten die in unserer
Gesellschaft vorkommen richtig deshalb
unterfallen diese auch dem Urteil des
EuGH was die Ausnahme zur IP-Adressen
Speicherung anbelangt schreiben Sie
selber in der Vorbemerkung der
Fragesteller und dann weiter weiter
Vorbemerkung der Fragesteller Ziel einer
effektiven Bekämpfungsstrategie muss es
nach Ansicht der Fragesteller daher sein
dass Entdeckungsrisiko für die
Täterinnen und Täter spürbar zu erhöhen
Ermittlungen
erleichtern und wirksam Prävention zu
leisten alle drei Punkte sind am besten
sind am besten
zu wenn wir den ermittleren Ermittler
das geben was sie fordern nämlich auch
eine rückwirkende Speicherung der
IP-Adressen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und gerade bei der Prävention
die beste Prävention ist die Täter aus
dem Verkehr zu ziehen und
schnellstmöglich dann dingfest zu machen
damit zukünftige zukünftige Taten
verhindert werden
und jetzt hat er EuGH Ihnen einen Weg
hierzu uns allen aufgezeigt und ein Jedi
darf sie feiern heute das Urteil des
EuGH so richtig amüsiert sehen sie aber
gar nicht aus weil der Ecke hart nämlich
mehr entschieden als das was sie nach
ihrer Ideologie wollen und jetzt können
wir diskutieren uns gegenseitig
vorwerfen Herr Kollege Buschmann Herr
Kuhle dass wir als wir 16 Jahre gemacht
haben oder nicht gemacht haben da waren
sie aber vier Jahre dabei umgekehrt
können wir sagen dass sie auch seit
vielen Jahren auf ihrer Position auf
ihrer Position beharren der EuGH hat
sich bewegt er ist nicht mehr der reine
Schutzpatron der Datenschützer und der
FDP er hat gesehen dass die zunehmende
Zahl von sexualisierter Gewalt
insbesondere im Internet gegenüber
Kindern auch hier eine Öffnung erfordert
und diese Möglichkeit gibt er uns wir
dürfen schlichtweg wenn wir es ernst
meinen dem Schutz von Kindern nicht
hinter diesen Möglichkeiten die der EuGH
uns alle gewährt zurückbleiben
das machen sie aber mit ihrem Vorschlag
big fies ich habe gar nichts dagegen
dass der Cookies machen weil das sind
nämlich auch die verkehrs- und
Standortdaten dabei nicht nur die
IP-Adressen aber eben nur für die
Zukunft gar keine Frage aber alle
ermittleren Ermittler sagen uns dass wir
auch für einen gewissen Zeitraum in die
Vergangenheit diese anlasslose
Datenspeicherung haben und dann mit
Richterbeschluss ausgelesen werden kann
die Frau Innenministerin die heute
sicherlich sonst auch da wäre aber aus
bekannten Gründen häufig da sein kann
wir sind Ihr Genesungswünsche hat dies
erkannt nachdem sie im Amt war und
Respekt sie hat ihre Meinung geändert
Herr Kollege Minister Puschmann machen
Sie dies auch sie werden sonst ihre
Aufgabe nicht gerecht und deswegen wird
die Frage wie Sie oder der Umgang mit
dieser Frage
der Lackmustest für die Ampel wie sie es
mit Schutz der Kinder ernst meint und ob
sie Sicherheit und Schutz für unsere
Bevölkerung insbesondere die schwächsten
gewährleistet oder tatsächlich auf ihren
alten Ideologien herumreitet und
Klientelpolitik betreibt nichts anderes
machen nämlich Grüne und FDP
letzte
Bemerkung
zum Nachdenken
der Täter von Wermelskirchen das ist der
Täter bei dem auch ein wenige Monate
altes Baby
Opfer wurde dieser Täter hatte Kontakt
mit dem Haupttäter aus Münster
allerdings über einen Aliasnamen
das hat man später herausbekommen
nachdem der Fall und werdenskirchen
bekannt wurde und ermittelt wurde man
hat schon damals unter dem Aliasnamen
versucht eine ip-adressenabfrage zu
machen allerdings gehen die aus
bekannten Gründen ins Leben man hätte
wenn es diese Regelung die wir heute
beantragen damals schon gegeben hätte
und da waren ja da können wir darüber
diskutieren dass wissen sie genau dass
die spds nicht mitgemacht hat wenn es
sie gegeben hätte dann hätten wir damals
diesen Täter aus Wermelskirchen früher
aus dem Verkehr ziehen können aber jetzt
ist es ihre Verantwortung und sie haben
die Verantwortung dafür dass solche
Fälle das solche Täter nicht frühzeitig
ermittelt werden können in Zukunft nicht
mehr passieren haben sie die
Verantwortung dafür alle Fälle die in
Zukunft stattfinden herzlichen Dank
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Alexander drum war das für die
Unionsfraktion
und weil er es angesprochen hat die
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer die
ist heute nicht hier im Bundestag die
ist wenn sie es vielleicht schon gehört
oder gelesen haben ja ebenfalls positiv
auf das Corona-Virus getestet worden wie
Olaf Scholz in dieser Woche danke
die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist tot lang
lebe die Vorratsdatenspeicherung das ist
der Tenor ihres zweiseitigen Antrags und
am Ende ist es so dass sie für die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung schlichtweg
immer neue Namen erfinden jetzt müssen
sie auch mal zuhören wenn sie die ganze
Zeit auf zwei Seiten vortragen aus der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben sie der
Vergangenheit einmal die
Mindestspeicherfrist gemacht heute
nennen sie es ip-adress-speicherung am
Ende muss ich sie wirklich fragen warum
betreiben sie immer noch Politik mit
diesem Tunnelblick und ertrum sie haben
mich angesprochen das was sie zitiert
haben ist letztlich die
Problembeschreibung die wir der
Fragestellung voran geschrieben haben
und am Ende frag ich sie wenn sie sagen
wir würden all die alte Ideologien auf
alten Ideologien herumreiten so haben
sie es gerade eben genannt frage ich Sie
was machen sie seit 16 Jahren nachdem
sie fünf Mal krachend auf die Nase
gefallen sind mit ihren Vorschlägen zur
Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ihr Antrag
wir auch fragen über Fragen offen
gelassen was macht man mit sechs Monaten
warum nicht zwölf oder 24 Monate warum
nicht fünf Jahre mit ihrem Beispiel
könnte man auch länger speichern wie
schützen Sie Personengruppen wie Anwälte
geistliche Journalisten Abgeordnete wenn
sie allen
vorratenspeicherung machen wie sie
riskieren doch mit ihrem Vorschlag ein
sechstes Mal krachen zu scheitern und
deswegen werden wir einen
verfassungsgemäßen Vorschlag bieten mit
dem wir nicht scheitern weil es ist
besser die Messer zu schärfen die
Straftäter zu ermitteln als mit
untauglichen verfassungswidrigen
Werkzeugen wiederzuscheitern und den
Zustand und der 16 Jahre
wiederherzustellen nämlich gar keine
Instrumente zu haben und das ist der
Unterschied zwischen uns und Ihnen sie
riskieren wiederzuscheitern und nichts
zu erreichen während wir uns auf den
verfassungswesen Boden mit schärferen
Werkzeugen den Straftätern nähern und
sie dingfest zu machen alles sagt man
für die FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
das steht ihnen zu bitte ja danke Herr
Kollege
höferingtervention die Sie hier die sie
hier gehalten aufgepasst es waren unter
drei Minuten insofern war es im Rahmen
dann aber Kollege Höferlin das hat man
doch gerade gesehen dass sie wieder
alles miteinander durcheinander
schmeißen dem sie wieder von
Vorratsdatenspeicherung in der Gänze
sprechen das ist nicht Inhalt unseres
Antrags und das ist auch nicht das was
der EuGH eröffnet hat der Eugen hat
ausdrücklich in einer dafür
Ausnahmefälle eröffnet dass bei schwerer
Kriminalität was bei schwerer
Kriminalität eine
anlasslose Speicherung der IP-Adressen
stattfinden kann und nichts anderes
verlangen wir von der Ampel von der
Bundesregierung vom Bundesjustizminister
die Innenministerin will es ja sowieso
und darum geht es wir
maximalen Schutz für Kinder und
Jugendliche vor sexuellem Missbrauch und
Kinderpornografie das glaube ich Ihnen
dass Sie es wollen aber sie machen es
nicht mit Quick Fries haben sie ein
Mittel an der Hand das für die Zukunft
übrigens nicht IP-Adressen sondern
verkehrs- und Standortdaten auslesen
will also die ganz bösen Daten nach
ihrer Lesart aber eben nicht die
Möglichkeit gibt Täter zu ermitteln für
ihre Taten sie können den Fall dass Sie
Kindesmissbrauch von Hanau von dem
Attentäter von Hanau wo auch nicht
nachvollzogen werden konnte welche 500
Personen auf seiner Homepage war bevor
er die Tat begangen hat weil eben keine
Auslösung der IP-Adressen möglich war
und sie können den Fall den ich Ihnen
gerade geschildert habe von
Wermelskirchen mit denen sie bei Quick
freeze scheitern werden und jetzt
gestehe ich Ihnen zu das habe ich in der
Rede gesagt die Positionen die wir
hatten was der EuGH dazu gesagt hat ich
fordere sie aber ich fordere ich fordere
Sie aber auf die FDP und die Grünen auch
ihre Positionen zu überprüfen und die
Möglichkeiten die der EuGH uns allen
ihnen gegeben hat tatsächlich auch zu
nutzen sonst werden sie auf andere
[Applaus]
eine Sekunde aber das soll erlaubt sein
und jetzt hat der Kollege Dr Thorsten
lieb das Wort für die FDP-Fraktion
ja noch dieser Kurzintervention und der
Antwort jetzt weiter also am Rednerpult
mit dem nächsten Abgeordneten Thorsten
lieb wird es sein für die FDP als ob man
im Rechtsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben uns
die Frage gestellt wir haben es geprüft
wir bleiben bei unserer Position wir
gehen in quick-freesley liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen und schade und
schade dass wir heutige Debatte so
völlig überraschungsfrei bislang
verlaufen ist man hätte die Schallplatte
von der Sitzung unmittelbar vor der
parlamentarischen Sommerpause einfach
hier ablaufen lassen können und wir
hätten keine neuen Erkenntnisse gewinnen
gehabt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der vergangene Dienstag war ein guter
Tag für die Freiheit und er war ein
guter Tag für die Bürgerrechte die
anlasslose allgemeine unterschiedliche
Vorratsdatenspeicherung von verkehrs-
und Standorten ist endgültig Geschichte
Rechtsgeschichte und das freut mich als
Rechtshistoriker ganz besonders liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im
Koalitionsvertrag haben wir vereinbart
einen rechtssicheren Vorschlag zu
unterbreiten für eine anlassbezogene
vorratsstaatenspeicherung die durch
richterlichen Beschluss dann eben
entsprechend auch abgesichert werden
kann und jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt dass
wir gekommen ich freue mich darauf dass
das Ministerium einen entsprechenden
Vorschlag unterbreiten wird und das ist
vor allem deswegen erforderlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen damit wir
endlich ein wirksames
ermittlungsinstrument in die Hand
bekommen die Wahrheit ist doch nach wie
vor wir haben stand heute nichts aber
auch gar nicht und immer wieder
Krokodilstränen über etwas zu weinen was
überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar und
einsetzbar ist das hört endlich auf
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen es bringt uns
kein Deutsch weiter es gibt nichts im
Moment und wir sorgen dafür dass es
etwas gibt in der Zukunft
das ist unsere Aufgabe das schleunigst
zu ändern und Sie liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen von der Union sollten doch
endlich dem Fetisch anlassloser
Vorratsdatenspeicherung entsagen es gibt
heute leise Andeutungen der Diskussion
aber es sollte doch jetzt wirklich gut
sein und es wäre klug es wäre klug von
ihnen wenn sie mit den nötigen Respekt
vor der Rechtsprechung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs das endlich eingestehen und
konstruktiv und konstruktiv an
vernünftigen Mitteln miteinander
arbeiten würden jetzt haben sie einen
Antrag vorgelegt und den habe ich mir
natürlich sehr genau angeguckt und ist
das eigentlich rechtssicher rechtssicher
was wir was sie vorschlagen wie Sie
behaupten ich sage nein sie fordern dazu
auf Praxis taugliche Regelung zur
Speicherung von Portnummern zu treffen
ich versuche es noch mal ich habe schon
mal gesagt Portnummern und iP-Adressen
sind technisch nicht das Gleiche sie
schreiben etwas rein zu dem der EuGH
kein Wort verliert sie schaffen neue
rechtsrisiken liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und sie fordern eine sechs-monatige
speicherverpflichtung ich lese ihnen das
auch das noch mal vor aus dem Urteil
wenn Sie erlauben Frau Präsidenten
absolut notwendiger begrenzter Zeitraum
woran machen Sie denn fest dass sechs
Monate genau dieser Zeitraum ist nicht
erkennbar aus dem Urteil war ist sie
streben eine befristete auf sechs Monate
befristete anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung an liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das ist
bestimmt nicht im Sinne des EuGH
mit anderen Worten sie machen mit dem
Antrag leider nichts anderes obwohl die
Diskussion die mehrfach angesprochen in
der Tat zentral wäre sie provozieren das
nächste Verfahren vom Europäischen
Gerichtshof sie provozieren die nächste
Klatsche sie provozieren dass sie
Sicherheitsbehörden auch zukünftig keine
wirksamen ermittlungsinstrumente in der
Hand haben und damit
gehen Sie genau im Gegensatz zu dem was
sie mit ihrem Antrag natürlich
richtigerweise ansprechen wie bekämpfen
wir effektiv sexualisierte Gewalt an
Kindern das ist dringend notwendig
unterliefern wir deswegen klare Aussage
von uns für die FDP-Fraktion ist dieser
Antrag alles andere als zustimmungsfähig
wir freuen uns auf den Vorschlag der
Bundesregierung auf das Angebot und dann
gehen wenn die die parlamentarische
Debatte darüber wie eine echte gute und
rechtskonform Umsetzung der
EuGH-Rechtsprechung erfolgen kann das
ist unser Auftrag und das werden wir als
Ampel liefern herzlichen Dank
ja das kündigt hier schon mal Thorsten
hey lieb an für die FDP-Fraktion
jetzt hören wir für die Union noch mal
einen reden der Christoph de Vries wird
das sein
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Kollege
Liebsch wir haben Zusammenhang mit
kindesbissbrauch von Fetisch spricht der
verhält sich in diesem Zusammenhang
ehrlich gesagt unanständig und
unangemessen das will ich an der Stelle
einmal ganz deutlich sagen
[Applaus]
Familienpolitiker der ich hier heute
sprechen darf in der Debatte 1 doch
deutlich geworden wem ist ein ernstes
Anliegen ist die Schwächsten in unserer
Gesellschaft zu schützen wir müssen ein
ernsthaftes Anliegen ist die einzige
verwertbare digitale Spur die zu den
Tätern dieser widerlichen Straftaten
führt auch zu nutzen und wir müssen
ernsthaftes Anliegen ist den
Kinderschutz über den Datenschutz zu
stellen wenn es um die Bekämpfung von
Kindesmissbrauch geht der darf sich und
der kann sich der befristeten
Speicherung von IP-Adressen in
Deutschland nicht entziehen meine Damen
und Herren
und und ich sag ja Herr Minister
Buschmann so einfach ist die Wahrheit
und das sage ich auch den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der FDP und der Grünen
beleben in einer Zeit im Moment wo wir
an allen Ecken und Enten ideologische
Dogmen über Bord werfen und zwar weil es
notwendig ist das gilt für Fragen von
Waffenlieferungen das gilt für den
wieder und Weiterbetrieb von Kohlekraft
und Kernkraftwerken und vieles mehr und
ich sage Ihnen liebe Kolleginnen von der
FDP werfen sie endlich ihr Datenschutz
Dogma bei der Bekämpfung von
Kindesmissbrauch auch über Bord das ist
auch notwendig meine Damen und Herren
schöpfen sie den gesetzgeberischen
Spielraum zur Speicherung aus hören Sie
auf die Innenminister der Länder die das
einhellig diese Woche gefordert haben
und unterstützen Sie die Position der
bundesinnenministerin fieser bei der
verpflichtenden Speicherung von
Verbindungsdaten ich sage ganz
ausdrücklich an dieser Stelle die
Innenministerin Feser hat die volle
Unterstützung der Union bei diesem Thema
und warum hat sie das gemacht sie hört
auf die Experten vom BKA auf die
landeskriminalämmt auf die
Kinderschutzorganisation Herr
Justizminister Buschmann hören Sie doch
endlich auch auf die Experten sie würden
wirklich was gutes tun an der Stelle und
das ist angesprochen worden der Quick
friesverfahren macht doch überhaupt
keinen Sinn das sagen die Experten
ebenfalls sie wollen Daten im Nachhinein
sichern die gar nicht mehr bestehen weil
sie die Speicherung nicht zulassen alles
was in der Vergangenheit liegt an
ermittlungsansätzen könnten ja Mittler
nicht mehr nutzen und deswegen ist das
was sie sagen auch keine Alternative
sondern das ist eine einzige Nebelkerze
die Sie in dieser Diskussion hier
verbreiten
und ich frage mich in dieser Diskussion
wo es eigentlich die Familienministerin
ich habe ihre Stimme dazu bisher nicht
vernommen die Innenministerin
befürwortet die Speicherung der
Justizminister lehnt sie ab aber was ist
eigentlich mit Frau Paus als
Familienministerin ist sie auch die
oberste kinderschützerin in Deutschland
und was hat sie dazu gestern gesagt wir
haben sie in der Fragestunde dreimal
gefragt wie ihre Positionen ist darauf
konnte oder wollte sie uns keine Antwort
sagen mit verlaut meine Damen und Herren
das ist auch ein Unding in einer so
zentralen Frage des Kinderschutzes in
Deutschland
[Applaus]
jeden einzelnen Fall aufzuklären und den
Kindesmissbrauch so wie er meint zu
bekämpfen dass das Angebot dieses
widerlichen Materials im Netz sinkt weil
jeder Angst haben muss erwischt zu
werden wenn er sich daran beteiligt und
das ist unsere Maxime meine Damen und
Herren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Christoph de Vries hat es angesprochen
es gab in dieser Woche eine Konferenz
der Innenminister der Länder die mehr
Möglichkeiten zur anlasslosen
Speicherung von
IP-Adressen fordern als bislang vom Bund
geplant
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion mehr Sicherheit
im digitalen Raum das ist unser Ziel und
wir müssen und wir werden unserem
demokratischen Rechtsstaat dafür alles
tun Schere und schwerste Straftaten zu
ahnen es ist etwas widersprüchlich dass
gerade die Union dies sind Zweifel zieht
auch wenn sie selbst immer wieder bei
dem Versuch gescheitert ist und versucht
ihre Verantwortung für diesen Bereichen
in den vergangenen 16 Jahren auf andere
Koalitionspartner die dritten
irgendwelche Gerichte und so weiter
abzuwälzen meine Damen und Herren sie
werden damit keinen Erfolg
und rechtsfreie Räume oder blinde
Flecken das werden wir in unserem
demokratischen Rechtsstaat nicht
zulassen machen sie sich da keine Sorgen
und deswegen liebe Mitbürgerinnen
Mitbürger die diese Debatte verfolgen
möglicherweise in Zweifel ziehen an
welche Seite wir kämpfenden streiten
genau dieser Versuch der für ja versucht
wird diesen Anschein zu erwecken das ist
eine Unverschämtheit in der Debatte und
das weiß ich in aller Entschiedenheit
zurück man kann
und das Gegenteil ist der Fall in der
vergangenen Woche hat der europäische
geruchshof tatsächlich und darauf haben
wir schon im Koalitionsvertrag Bezug
genommen sein Urteil gesprochen und wir
haben in unserem Koalitionsvertrag auch
ausdrücklich festgestellt dass dieses
Urteil unser Anlass sein wird wenn wir
beim anlasslosen Speichern von Daten
sind tatsächlich eine rechtssichere
Regelung zu finden der Justizminister
Marco Buschmann hat innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit schon getwittert ist ein
historisches Urteil Herr Justizminister
in aller Offenheit es ist natürlich in
einer langen Folge von Entscheidung ein
weiterer Punkt und gibt uns deutliche
Leitplanken vor wie wir denn tatsächlich
zu einer rechtssicheren Lösung kommen
werden und darum auch die klare Ansage
die deutlicher Erklärung all das was das
EuGH Urteil uns ermöglicht um
ep-adressen rechtssicher zu speichern
werden wir auch zur Verfolgung schwerer
und schwerster Straftaten tun es wird
keinen Zweifel geben meine Damen und
aber aber und das ist die Grenze dessen
wir werden nicht dazu gehen dass wir
wieder etwas konstruieren wo wir nur
darauf setzen dass es am Ende scheitert
vor Gericht und das ist der feine und
klare Trennstrich den wir meine Damen
und Herren eben bei der Verfolgung der
schweren und schwersten Straftat nicht
geben würden und es ist im EuGH-Urteil
eindeutig erklärt worden warum eine
allgemeine Speicherung von IP-Adressen
zur zulässig erklärt werden aber ein
feiner Unterschied zwischen verkehrs-
und Standortdaten gemacht wird man muss
es schon genau lesen die Rand Nummer 100
gibt uns hier den Hinweis auf
verschiedene technische Verfahren haben
wir sogar vorab ob es die login-falle
ist ob es ein aktuell diskutiertes
Verfahren quick freeze dass wir noch
nachträglich definiert haben auch
aufgenommen und ich kann Ihnen
versichern und deswegen ist der
Zungenschlag in dieser Debatte wirklich
schräg wenn das Ziel so einen ist und
sie ein so dünnen Antrag stellen dann
geht es ihnen nicht tatsächlich darum
eine rechtssichere Lösung zu finden
sondern sie versuchen diese Debatte zu
missbrauchen von ihren eigenen Versagen
den 16 Jahren abzuweichen und sie
versuchen von ihrem eigenen Versagen
abzulenken und eine tatsächliche nicht
gangbare Lösung hier zu finden und da
ist der Unterschied zwischen
sozialdemokratischen und
christdemokratischer Innenpolitik meine
Damen und Herren
und es widerstrebt mir ausdrücklich und
das muss ja wirklich noch mal in aller
Klarheit in aller Öffentlichkeit
dargelegt werden dass der Anschein
erweckt wird wir versuchen hier Regelung
und Möglichkeiten nicht zu nutzen um die
Begehung schwerer und schwerster
Straftaten gerade bei den widerlichen
Fällen des Kindesmissbrauchs zu
ermöglichen oder zu begünstigen wenn das
allen Ernstes ihr Vorwurf ist dann ist
das keine Grundlage um nur in die Nähe
einer gemeinsamen Arbeit oder Zustimmung
zu kommen korrigieren Sie sich meine
Damen und Herren von der cdu/csu oder
wir haben keine Basis und hier einen
Meter voranzukommen das sage ich aller
Klarheit
und uns ist auch bewusst dass eine
Speicherung ob kürzer oder länger auch
ein nicht zu vernachlässigender Eingriff
in unsere Grundrechte ist und genau das
werden wir an dieser Stelle auch anders
regulieren dass wir können uns auch
nicht davon abhängig machen dass
möglicherweise private Dritte diese
Daten speichern oder nicht und was auch
nicht geht in der Debatte ist dass wir
zulassen das dritte Staaten auf anderer
Rechtsgrundlage möglicherweise Daten und
liefern das meine Damen und Herren kann
nicht der Anspruch der Strafverfolgung
sein ich bin der festen Auffassung wir
werden eine grundrechtsschonende Lösung
finden die auf der einen Seite die
Grundrechte derjenigen die von diesen
schweren und schwersten Straftaten
Betroffenen Mitbürgern Mitbürger das
sind unsere Kinder die in der
körperlichen unversehrt dort in ihrem
Leben bedroht sind dieses Grundrecht
werden wir schützen und auf der anderen
Seite die Grundrechte der anderen
betroffenen Bürgerinnen und Bürger schon
das ist unsere Linien dieser Debatte
meine Damen und Herren wir werden diese
Frage in Einklang bringen wir werden das
auch tatsächlich relativ zügig ich gucke
in Richtung des Justizministers der im
Übrigen eine Verabredung mit der
Innenministerin hat nun eine
entsprechende Regelung auf den Weg
bringen ich bin mir sehr sicher dass wir
in den Beratung des Innenausschusses und
der weiteren beteiligtenausschüsse
dieses an der einen oder anderen Stelle
noch diskutieren werden Nachschärfen
werden aber es wird kein rechtsfreien
Raum geben es wird keine Lösung geben wo
es nicht nachher möglich ist die
Straftäter dieser widerlichen Straftaten
zu verfolgen das ist ein Unding dass die
Union uns mittelbar oder öffentlich das
unterstellt hat das weiß ich in aller
Klarheit für die ampelfraktion zurück so
geht es nicht
sagt Sebastian Hartmann für die
SPD-Fraktion ja eine teils doch sehr
scharf geführte Debatte hier zu diesem
Thema aber kein Wunder ist ja auch es
geht um schwerste Verbrechen und es geht
um eine Diskussion rund um die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung die ja schon 15
Jahre mindestens die deutsche Politik
beschäftigt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit nunmehr 15
Jahren wird uns erzählt dass die
anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung ganz
einfach Straftaten auf decken lassen
können das aber ist de facto falsch
Beispiele die die Absurdität dieser
Debatte zeigen haben wir zu Haufen
massenhaft und wir haben sie auch hier
im Haus gehört aber mentiert wird immer
mit den krassesten Fällen nicht nur mit
sexualisierter Gewalt der Drogen hat
auch recht den Rechtsterrorismus
angesprochen
aber wir können uns das auch mal ganz
genau im Detail anschauen am Beispiel
des NSU es wird nämlich immer wieder
gesagt den NSU hätte man verhindern
können hätte man die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt wenn man
sich das aber mal genauer anschaut war
doch folgendes der Fall
wir hatten circa 20 Millionen
Verbindungsdaten
14.000 Namen und Adressen wurden
gespeichert und hat man die Täter
ermittelt nein man hat sie nicht
ermittelt nach mehr als einer Dekade
haben sie sich selbst enttarnt
seit über 15 beweist dass das Argument
nicht zieht her trugen
seit ich versucht die Union und das
Innenministerium Grüße gehen raus an
nennt sie Feser mit möglichst
emotionalen Beispielen die die
massenüberwachung der gesamten
Bevölkerung durchzusetzen und fast
genauso langsam uns höchste Gerichte so
geht es nicht 2010
2014/2016/2020 und jetzt 22 sind sie mit
ihrer Politik vor
verfassungsgerichtend gescheitert sie
haben noch keinen Vorschlag vorgelegt
denn irgendeiner Form verfassungskonform
war und jetzt mal im Ernst wenn man fünf
Mal vor Gerichten gesagt bekommt das
Pferd dass man reitet ist tot dann
sollte man endlich absteigen
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union statt mal das eigene Verhältnis
zum Rechtsstaat zu reflektieren stellen
Sie sich heute allen Ernstes wieder
hierhin und machen einen offenen
verfassungswidrigen Vorschlag zu einer
anlasslosen Vorratsdatenspeicherung der
nichts anderes ist ihre ip-speicherung
nichts anderes ist es wenn es ihnen
wirklich
wenn es ihnen wirklich um den
Kindesschutz ginge dann würden sie die
Möglichkeiten auf den Tisch setzen die
meine Kollegin Frau Lob auch schon
erwähnt hat nämlich die die seit 16
Jahren nicht behandelt worden sind und
Erde Fries wenn sie gestern bei der
regierungsbefragung zugehört hätten dann
hätten sie gehört wie unsere
Familienministerin gesagt doch sie hat
gesagt dass die dass sie gegen die
anlasslose massenüberwachung ist ich
finde das ist klar genug das einzige
das einzige was Ihnen einfällt ist
weiter überwachen und weiter speichern
und das bei allen Internetnutzern es
zeigt dass der Kompass den sie haben in
grundrechtsfragen völlig verloren ist
mit Quick Fries und mit Login fallen die
wir haben geben wir den
Sicherheitsbehörden endlich
grundrechtskonforme und zielgerichtete
Instrumente an der Hand statt dass sie
weiterhin auf die Gerichtsentscheide
warten müssen die in zwei und vielen
Jahrestakt von der von den Gerichten
einkassiert werden geben wir den
Sicherheitsplan rechts sichere
Instrumente an die Hand mein letzter
Satz ich empfehle
der letzte Satz ich empfehle der Union
mehr Selbstreflexion und inhaltlicher
Aufarbeitung dass das am an diesem
Antrag erkennt man dass das dringend
notwendig ist danke schön
ja Mischverfahren war das für die Grünen
glitzeriterin zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt und nach dieser
Debatte
kann man nicht nur erahnen sondern hat
gesehen warum es nicht nur diverse
Gerichtsurteile des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs zu diesem
Thema gab sondern auch ein so lange
Diskussion darüber die ja noch nicht
beendet ist Einigkeit ist natürlich das
ist um schwerste Verbrechen wie
Darstellung sexualisierte Gewalt an
Kindern sexuellen Missbrauch dass das
verhindert werden muss aber was ist das
Mittel dazu und wo ist die Grenze wo ist
die Balance zwischen Freiheit und
Sicherheit also man wartet hier auf
einen Vorschlag der regierungskoal